if I could start by asking you perhaps
briefly outline from each of your
perspectives your thoughts on the child
care announcements in the spring budget
and we can we can move on from there if
I start perhaps with a beginner yes
thanks very much
um focusing first on the labor supply
side of things
um I think we would say that based on
our research we can expect those the
announcement of the spring budget to
move more people into work
but mostly we would say this would
happen once it is fully implemented we
have previous research on the on the
free entitlement of three to
four-year-olds and found that 15 hours
of child care provision is was not
enough to move women into work whereas
when children then move into Primary
School which is like full-time care we
did find a um a significant effect both
on labor force participation and
unemployment
so for that reason we would think we
would expect
these effects to kick in once it's fully
implemented in September 2025
um at the time of our research we did
speculate that the 382 four-year-old
entitlement was kicking in a bit too
late for women they might possibly have
already disengaged from the labor market
so this announcement now is obviously an
earlier Supply which fits more
seamlessly with maternity leave and
therefore could be we could hope to see
some some bigger effects and it's also I
think a benefit that we have it more
unified approach now across the ages of
children which might be beneficial
and I think there's some staying with
the benefits right now there's some
other side effects that we should note
one of which is that if these measures
are good for Child Development then
obviously we're enhancing the
productivity of the Next Generation and
Recent research that we've carried out
also shows that childcare is very good
for the mental health of mothers and
that's an aspect often overlooked and in
turn can lead to a higher labor Supply
as well
um now maybe looking a little bit more
at the risks in terms of the labor
Supply I think it's been noted before in
this um committee that we have to be
clear this subsidy is only for 38 weeks
so in term time I know it can be used
across all the weeks of the year but
that reduces the the offer to in fact I
think 22 hours per month
um per week excuse me
um also I think there is a bit of a
decision to be made whether it should be
offered for training and education and
potentially also for looking to work so
this is a small
um these are I think things that could
be looked at but another bigger point to
stress is that the um
the the labor Supply effect given the
the amount of subsidy that we're
offering is quite modest
um you know the scale of the subject and
the labor Supply effect to be expected
is small and the reason for this is that
we're crowding out a lot of private
investment into child care that is
already happening and we're also
crowding out a lot of informal child
care that is already happening this is
what we've seen for our analysis of the
three to four year olds and
um at the time we looked at the Family
Resources survey and found that the the
one-year-olds which would be kind of the
the group that we're looking at here 62
of them are already in some form of
child care be it formal or informal so
I'd um in fact I mean the the end result
of offering these subsidies
um not a lot of children will be moving
into child care who have not otherwise
been in child care already and hence
they're quite modest effects on on labor
Supply and connected with this if I may
go on
there is we know from the extension
entitlements for three to four year olds
that um it's more affluent parents who
benefit from this and so against this
background I think it is a question that
should be raised whether
um it's it's fair to to offer like a
flood rate
um subsidy to All Families or whether we
should have a tapering off at the at the
a higher income
points of the income District we'll come
back to yeah okay so I think so it's
something that um you know would give us
more scope perhaps to to Target
families further down the income
distribution and also the children which
brings me on to the child care side of
it and I I don't want to talk too long
here but I suppose
um what we know about child development
is that it's it's beneficial for
children If the child care offered in a
setting is better than what they would
otherwise experience this so-called
counterfactual which could be at home or
in the informal arrangements or whatever
settings children are in and so the
quality is is what would be the decisive
factor and I'm sure that you're going to
ask
um or we will talk about in more detail
about all these aspects of quality and
how the funding is related to that and
also the types of children that we will
be getting into Child Care through a um
through an offer which is for Working
Families because we do know that the
most disadvantaged children are in
families that are not necessarily
Working Families but yeah I don't want
to take too much thank you thank you
I'll go over to Professor Lloyd and then
thank you
well to start I think the proposals in
the budget are the most exciting ones
we've had since 1998 when the national
Child Care strategy was announced
but as far as the implementation of
these proposals have concerned
I like Vegeta I foresee many problems
because of the system we have
and very particularly because they are
focused on relieving parental child care
costs there are many other ways that
other systems do address that issue and
indeed it is extremely urgent but unless
we address this issue at the same time
as the completely unacceptable
conditions of the child care Workforce
I very much doubt that we are going to
get to a successful implementation we
have a situation where now parents are
reducing the number of powers that they
pay for with or without the help of the
tax-free child care or on the universe
credit
and of course they will still take the
funded hours so at our providers are
currently struggling with a reduction in
income because of this this is really
happening and it's happening fast
and then we're also struggling with the
workforce absolutely having reached the
end of the road exhausted after covet
now dealing with the cost of living
crisis
they are leaving in droves we've seen in
enormous reduction in the number of
well-qualified at level three people
still you know working here and
similarly with graduates
and it can only get worse
and what do you think I mean what do you
think other solutions to that obviously
investing in the workforce but it's
about how mechanistically could should
the budget or the government being
um I am not here to offer you some cost
neutral suggestions but I'm sure I don't
need to remind you of the work done by
my colleagues here and others about the
payback to the exchecker and the payback
to communities and societies of
investing more money and I I hope to
talk later if I may about my experience
working with the Irish government on a
new funding model for the early years
system but core funding another form of
supply-side funding is key we cannot
expect to pay decent wages and improve
the working conditions of the child care
Workforce through these per capita rates
that are being paid per capita won't do
it and as Vegeta has already said there
are doubts about the amount of money
that will come towards the three and
four-year-olds and you know although for
school on the twos and two-year-olds it
looks better
but you know there will just be for five
pound fifty eight pound 11 pounds yeah
around you know but really
we cannot expect providers without
increased core funding which has
certainly what happened in Ireland and
without quite
serious public management because the
work of the international center for the
study of the mixed economy of Charity
that Professor Helen Penn and I
established in 2007 and we are pleased
to sitting here behind me and um
but that work was really looking at the
system of marketized child care and the
Dynamics of marketized child care and
whether it those systems deliver on the
policy aims that governments have and
successive governments have had the same
policy aim social Mobility family
economic well-being and social justice
including all children
and the current system doesn't deliver
on those policy aims
so
core funding additional funding that's
going into the system even if nothing
else happens but the proposals that
we've heard in the spring budget should
be conditional
without conditionality money will not
arrive where it is most needed we've
seen we see that across the world in
marketized systems but particularly
there will be an influx of private for
profit providers many with a background
which has nothing to do with child care
and Early Education
who and it always happens when
substantial public money comes into a
system
now it's understandable but it's got to
be managed
okay
um and I'll come to Christine thank you
very much I think the spring budget is
very clearly a statement of intent so we
will see by 2027 that spending on the
free entitlement has doubled over its
current level which in turn has doubled
since 2010. this is essentially taking
the close to final step in establishing
a new branch of the welfare state uh so
compared to 25 years ago the government
has very clearly made a decision that it
has a role to play and it needs to find
resources to play that role in those
first five years of life so I think that
statement of intent and the resources to
back that up will be welcomed by many
people in the sector and recognize the
goals of the early air system like
brigitta and Eva have set out in terms
of child development in terms of
supporting parents to work but most
crucially I think in this budget in
terms of supporting younger family
families with younger children with the
cost of child care we estimate that
around 85 percent of the spending done
through this these new entitlements will
be spent on Child Care hours that
families are already using and already
paying for so that is not a silly thing
to want to do it's not silly we know
that those families with the youngest
children
by a very long margin face the highest
child care costs and struggle the most
with those costs it's certainly not a
foolish thing for the government to wish
to relieve some of the pressures and
tensions on those budgets but it does
mean that when we think of this or build
this as or discuss this as a labor
Supply policy we also need to keep in
mind that most of the spending we're
doing is not directly related to labor
supply per se
and I think that reflects another part
of this new branch of the welfare state
that we've we've come on which has
really been a journey from the early
introduction as An Early Education
policy which you know is why this sits
within the department for education and
why this is of such great interest to
this committee that it was initially
viewed as being about supporting
children to become ready to start
schooling and to access that Early
Education that it was felt that they
needed we've moved quite a long way
since then and that's been a kind of
gradual process with ever more emphasis
on the labor Supply aspect of this child
care offer and I think what we saw in
the budget was really quite a decisive
step in that direction to say really the
priority here and the focus here is
labor Supply and supporting parents to
work and supporting families with child
care costs I say that because of the
targeting of these policies which the
committee has already heard about from
brigada and Eva in terms of support for
working families and I say that because
of the the rhetoric around this offer
and the way that the chancellor has kind
of asked the sector to to deliver these
entitlements what that's left us with is
a system which is administered by the
department for Education as brigitta
mentions based on ideas about the school
system about term time about 30 hours
being a full-time place
but has these is being asked to to do
the job of supporting parents to work
and so that leaves us with you know
several real Oddities in the system uh
bergita referenced whether these hours
are going to be available for parents
who are training or in education or
parents who are seeking to work what we
know about the current 30-hour
entitlement is that there is a waiting
period essentially parents are asked are
advised to apply for their 30-hour codes
four to ten weeks before the start of
the term in which they wish to take that
offer up which means they need to be
working four to ten weeks before the
start of the term in which they wish to
take that offer up so I think there are
questions here about the design of this
and how that will support people into
work there are also fundamental
questions at the top end of the spectrum
with the decision to cap the entitlement
and and exclude families where one
earner is earning more than a hundred
thousand pounds per year obviously
that's a lot of money obviously those
families are well off but that blunt
Cliff Edge that's built into the system
creates some very odd incentives where a
parent with two very young children in
London would be better off refusing a
pay rise of almost 40 000 pounds almost
forty thousand pounds they would leave
on the table rather than give up on the
child care support through these new
entitlements which strikes me as a
slightly odd design feature to put into
a policy that we think is supposed to be
about promoting labor Supply and
supporting parents to work
but I think the first order
consideration here is the deliverability
of this policy we estimate that after
even before anybody changes how much
child care they're using the government
will now be buying around 80 percent of
the preschool child care hours in
England when you're buying 80 of the
market for anything you really have to
be sure you're getting the price right
because if you set that price too low
providers may choose not to offer point
in comparison to that where would it be
starting from so at the moment it's
about 50 right so this is already the
government has quite a heavy weight in
that market and that has caused some
distortions which I'm sure we'll discuss
more but this is really we're reaching
the point where
all of the Cross Subs the channels for
cross-subsidizing the channels for sort
of working around Whitehall when it gets
that rate wrong those are by and large
being shut off which poses great risks
on the other hand there are also risks
of setting funding rates far too high
particularly in the context of a market
which is a mixed economy which is
regulated but where quality and prices
are are difficult for Regulators to
observe so there is a risk here of
inefficient public spending as well if
we go too far in the other direction
without commensurately increasing the
quality of the Care on offer
um it is the rates that we have seen at
least for the two-year-olds and the
under twos do look sort of in line with
or more generous than current market
prices for child care so that is an
encouraging sign for three and
four-year-olds the picture is a little
bit less clear that that those rates
really will be adequate but I think for
me the fundamental question here is
setting these rates is really hard
getting them right is really hard we've
seen that the process in the past has
been driven quite a lot around spending
reviews or set piece announcements or
when does the sector get so much into
crisis that we think it's going to fall
over and maybe we should whack a little
bit more money and
when you're buying 80 of the market that
sort of ad hoc way of setting your
funding rates and determining them that
feels riskier than ever before so
getting the process right to set and to
review the evidence and to revise these
funding rates I think that will be
absolutely crucial thank you I think
it's a very important point and and you
know I just want to come back to you
because you've advocated in written
evidence wholesale reform of the child
care Market I mean what would you see
that as looking like what
where would that end up
end up with a much more
you'll have the Legacy and the legacy of
the model of the downward pressure of
the
um
nurseries class model you know Nursery
class in primary maintain primary model
but
the
[Music]
um
in fact to step away from this and look
at it actually
free the All or Nothing approach I think
as Christina said in her submission is
not the norm across Europe the norm is
income related fees for parents capping
parental fees having a decision about
how much it is reasonable to expect
parents to pay from household income for
the child care and Early Education for
their system
so
um
Scotland has gone one further and it
said 30 hours for all children
also aiming to get in the children whose
parents are not going to work or and
aiming this as part of an anti-poverty
strategy and I think we should bear the
anti-poverty aspect of these measures in
in mind all the time given the present
child poverty rates which are appalling
for this country so
it is a managed Market with much more
public
input much more public management I see
and I think of the work by one of the
economists whose work I really like
apart from the work of my colleagues
which is Mariana matsukata who talks
about from a policy perspective we need
to shape the market rather than fix the
market but to do that we first have to
ask the question what kind of Market do
we want
so the focus goes on to the partnership
the kind of partnership that the
government has with the providers now we
have a complex mixed economy of
childcare because we've got public
providers we've got private for-profit
and not-for-profit
in Germany they're largely
not-for-profit you know and if one is a
for-profit provider there is no Public
Funding
so only about three percent of the
providers in that market are for profit
but we have that complex Arrangement and
that needs looking at so there are big
changes but again the importance of the
outcomes for children the importance of
the benefits for the for communities and
societies n40x Checker in the ends you
know there's interesting research I mean
my colleague at the open University
Jerome de hay now is an interesting
research on creating a system where
parents work fewer hours but there is
free child care you know I mean and what
a payback to the exchecker is from those
models what you know the the new
economics Foundation has doesn't work on
that there is the target guarantee which
is being rolled out in the rest of
Europe ipbr's looked at that
there are all sorts of ways
taking the market and of course some of
us would say we've got to look at this
excessive profit making that is going on
within the child care Market most of the
children receive their Early Education
within this Market you know the
proportion who receive their Early
Education I'm still using that term
in public provision is is about it so we
really are talking most most children on
the five
so it it is very important to Grapple
with the role of
profit extraction from this sector the
role of private equity and hedge funds
in our submission Helen and I said you
know we are slightly encouraged by the
bank of England
[Music]
establishing or planning a stress test
of the role of the largely unregulated
second banking sector in this country
the role of private Equity because there
is concern about the stability of the UK
economy well we've been concerned about
the stability of the
Early Childhood Education and Care
system for over 20 years
thank you thank you I'm going to hand
over to Miriam thank you chair
um
we've been talking about the impact of
the budget announcement in terms of
getting parents back into the workplace
and I think the government's own figures
suggest that the policy if implemented
uh properly which I know is is Up For
Debate uh would result in 60 000 parents
returning to the workforce now my math
tells me that's about 5 300 pounds per
returning parent and if that parent
returned on a median wage they might pay
three and a half thousand pounds back to
Executive so to my mind in tax that's
not a particularly good outcome for the
taxpayer so um what would be a better
way if your aim was to get as many
parents back into the workforce as
possible what would be a better more
efficient way of doing that
um Christine
well I think I think that's an important
point and I think when we think about
the exchequer impact of this policy you
know this is a big giveaway for the
average full-time woman who is the
average woman who is working full-time
this giveaway is worth more than getting
rid of all of their income tax and all
of their National Insurance
contributions which is a way of
suggesting that at least in the sort of
short term it's unlikely to pay for
itself I do think that that's not
necessarily the only benefit that the
government is hoping to realize from
this reform so we spoke earlier about
the costs that families pay for very
young children in child care and it's
not that this money is sort of going
away and disappearing out into the ether
it is relieving pressures on family
budgets for families who are already
working and are already paying for
formal child care
but I think there's also an important
question here about what what the aim is
in terms of Labor Supply we think that
there are benefits for people going back
into work and reasons if we're trying to
think about reasons why the government
might wish to intervene to make that be
so Chief amongst those might be things
like the gender wage Gap and and
promoting greater equality between men
and women in the labor market or things
like the long-term impacts of taking a
few years out of the labor market and
what impact that has but those are those
are
um ideological aims so for example you
know in countries where that have higher
female participation in the workplace
you tend to get a great agenda pay Gap
because the more women that return back
to work the more formal jobs are created
in childcare and elderly care they tend
to be low paid so therefore the average
wage of a woman decreases in the gender
big now it depends whether you think
that matters but
you know the polling suggests that the
vast majority of parents of under threes
would prefer to work less if they had a
choice now I understand that for many
families there is no Financial Choice
but why is it inherently a good thing to
try to increase participation in the
workplace for parents of under threes so
my next Point actually was going to be
exactly along those lines what the obr's
estimates suggest is that most of these
60 000 women or parents but largely
women who will be entering work are
likely to be working an average of 16
hours per week what we know is that the
benefits in terms of the gender wage Gap
in terms of those long-term career pay
and progression points those are much
much less when people are working
part-time roles so I do think there is
an important question about being clear
that labor Supply in and of itself is
not always
an aim a goal a necessary thing of
course parents preferences do play a
role but equally it would not be a silly
thing for the government to say you know
we have an interest beyond the exchequer
cost in helping people to live full
complete satisfied lives and if what
they choose to do if what they wish to
do is go out into paid work and use
those skills in education they've built
up then we have an interest in support
of that yes that's really interesting so
what you're saying is actually the aim
should be
um that to help women who want to keep
their hand in a career for example to
help people with cost of living If the
child could costs are too high to kind
of be a more flexible help to what
people already need but that may not
have the big bang impact on hundreds of
thousands of people returning to work so
you know and I think that's I think
that's a very good model and aim but
what would you know what should the
chancellor do if he wants to get more
parents back to work what would be a
better policy and I'll go to either if
that's okay
yes I have to come back I'm afraid to my
first point that if we're really serious
that has to be much more rigorous reform
and we have to start with the child care
Workforce Now in the Nordic countries
they started 50 years ago and you know
it we have lost so many opportunities to
look at all parts of the system you know
that really without the people we don't
get the outcomes for the children which
and we might not even get the enjoyable
experiences you know it is so ex but
um I also agree with what Christina's
just been saying about
what we see in systems that have good
support for the Early Childhood
Education and Care system is that by and
large those governments also more
generously support parents in their task
of childhood really because the
importance to communities and societies
and through the exchequer is so imp you
know in huge of what parents do yes and
it is being neglected and the way you
know a child-friendly community with
more facilities which means more money
for
Community initiatives but also local
authorities who can play a role they're
the local Authority role in all this is
absolutely crucial and just as an aside
if you look at the Nordic countries like
Norway which has always had a mixed
market economy of child care then you
say okay five and a half million
inhabitants 425 local authorities they
do a fair amount of micromanaging there
you know so it is crucial we know from
the you know the last
uh Owen's household satellite satellite
accounts I looked at you know calculated
the price of Parental and informal child
get a contribution to the economy of
that is huge and second only to
transport you know in terms of and of
course we'll look at ourselves you know
well in my case it will be looking after
grandchildren now not children so much
but um
you know parents spend far more time
looking after their children than the
children will ever spend informal
provision which brings me on to my next
question actually which is one of our
Witnesses was Anne Fennell who chairs
mothers at home matter which is a group
that support women who wants to be able
to stay at home while their children are
young and choose to do that and and she
pointed out that you know all this 3.2
billion pounds is to help families
uncondition that both parents return to
work for a setting them arouse and you
put your child in formal state-funded
child care and what she was making that
exact point that the contribution that
well of both parents obviously but
others make not just to the current
economy in terms of doing out of labor
but in also the kind of foundations of
attachment and emotional security that
they lay in their children for later
life should also be recognized by the
government whether that's through the
tax system as it is in other countries
or in vouchers or other ways of doing
that would you support some kind of
system that was more flexible that would
support women in their choice and not
just push them in One Direction
my ideal system would support parents
fathers and mothers in their choices
yeah I can see that if only from a
public health perspective the the first
year is crucial the you know the sport
for mothers and I think really would
like to see the whole first year you
know
devoted to well-paid leave that will
encourage parents take it in terms to
stay at home with um infant you know so
yes I would want both so the true Choice
can only be there if and I also want to
say that of course the very welcome
increase in child care support that will
be available under
um the benefit system you know Universal
Credit
has got quite strong conditionality
attached now to it and that really
worries me a bigger way of seeing
explosion in the number of young
families on needing Universal Credit and
basically our Early Childhood Education
and Care system is hold seriously below
the water line so how can we impose
conventionality than on mothers of
one-year-olds and so on if there is no
well-functioning system for them to make
use of yeah and this is crucial and we
had the lady who chairs the gingerbread
charity that supports single parents and
I think around 80 of single parent
families are on Universal Credit and now
these often mothers are going to face
this compulsion to return to work even
if their children have been through you
know emotional
um you know trauma and things like that
from family breakdown and they feel that
they now have no choice but to return to
work and leave their their child so
there's all sorts of problems around the
the conditionality which only a good
system yeah can can cope with and and
compassionate Society yeah yeah and so
it finally um just to pick up on a point
you made you made a point about and if I
heard this wrong apologies that
um you know early Years Daycare
essentially can have a positive impact
in uh children's productivity later on
in life I'd be interested to hear more
about that because the research I've
shown shows very much the opposite for
most families which is a secure
attachment with primary caregiver so
normally mom in the first year of Life
lays the foundation of resilience in
times of stress that actually allows
young people and young adults to cope
much better with life and that there's
some links now between children who have
been in daycare from an early age and
who are less able you know have more
anxiety issues as teenagers and young
adults
um so I don't know you know it's very
different to the research I've seen so
I'd be interested to hear more I think
um in terms of the research there is not
a lot of research about very young
children because most countries offer
child care for three to four year olds
or from two years only it so to find any
good research for younger children is
very difficult but the evidence I have
seen and I have reviewed this literature
recently is that it is it crucially
depends on the quality of the child care
so again what I said earlier it always
depends on what the counterfactual is
what are we comparing is it a secure
home life is it a more chaotic home life
and what is the the quality of the care
that you're sending the child to and in
low quality settings like they're
examples in Canada where there was quite
a cheap hotel a daycare offered to very
young children
and the evidence shows that there are
behavioral problems coming out of that
more than in social
emotional well-being is affected whereas
academically you don't see that many
differences but you this is an
indication that it can be stressful but
it's related to many parameters again it
depends on how many hours do you send
very young children into child care with
long hours being perhaps more more
distressing for the child so that you
know it's many dimensions that you have
to compare essentially what you're
saying is this Quantum of funding unless
there is some significant change it's
unlikely to be able to fund the kind of
quality provision that would be an
improvement for most children on but I
mean this this is leads us onto a whole
different quite complicated debate so
the one thing is how do we Define Child
Care Quality and this is difficult we
have I've done research on this as well
as you know that you know you can
describe Child Care along the lines of
structural Dimensions how qualified are
the child care teachers what are the
child to adult ratios and the literature
does not often find a very strong
relationship between those structural
characteristics Because the actual
quality the experience of the child what
you would call Process quality is
something different it's the experience
that you have and it's not necessarily
linked to the academic degree of the
teacher that you're facing so it's quite
difficult to Define quality but let's
say I mean these other more refined
measures including offset ratings which
we find to be quite successful in
pointing out high quality Child Care
settings in our research these more you
know difficult to collect measures let's
say we we can use them to to create high
quality settings but then I think the
other important question is which
children are you actually enticing to
attend those things yeah
those settings and if you link link free
childcare to to working we know from the
evidence that it's going to be more High
income children and not the children who
stand to benefit the most and in all in
order to reach those children and this
is you were talking about the aims of
the policy before and Christine has
talked about the labor Supply and also
the helping children parents with young
children in their in their expenditures
but the third pillar obviously is the um
enhancing child development side and it
possibly you could extend this to
include closing the gaps between
children of different backgrounds and
that leads us onto the question of how
do we reach those children who stand to
benefit most and that's an entirely
different aim to how do we
fill the workforce with it it's very
different yeah but can I just at one
point and then I'll finish which is um
creating the this support for Working
Families obviously directs it towards
the higher ups but even if it's
Universal like the the 15-hour
entitlement we have a a proportion of
parents who will not send their children
we know that take-up is incomplete and
also the current two-year-old offer and
I think that's a whole different thing
that should be looked at how can we get
those parents because it's almost like
reverse selection on on the potential
games that's what the literature finds
the very hard to reach are the children
who would benefit most from going into
high quality child care has risen over
time hasn't it but it's still about 76 I
think
yes in the two-year-old offer it's
um yeah it's around 70 and and although
93 percent ish go to take up the the
four three to four year old offer
there's still these seven percent are an
interesting group I think for example
children with English as an additional
language and in our research we have
shown that they can benefit most from
means not just poor families it's also
language you know early language
acquisition and and so I think that's
important to look at as well thank you
very much and I'll hand over to Ian
right good morning and apologies for
being late I I'm very sorry
um we've kind of skirted into this or
already but I wonder what you sort of
flesh out about extending the universal
three hours entitlement and and do you
think it's the most effective use of of
government resources
um for child care subsidies of this
nature and do you think there are any
potential risks and and and do the
economic advantages outweigh the the
social disadvantages of vice versa
anyone carry on please because Lloyd do
you want to start on that one right
um I I think you have missed some of the
discussion and that's that's because we
have uh discussed this to an extent but
it's very good to to hear this
emphasized again because it's so
important where the public money goes so
um from my perspective you know is there
something more effective for this group
of children we could be doing with the
money
is there an opportunity cost as it were
the what does seem to be the case when
again when you look across Europe is
that
a system is
navigate if it is generous
then it becomes attractive to parents so
in fact you will see that the level of
informal care goes down and parents are
happy this is definitely what happens in
the Nordic countries a generous system
that is seen as high quality by parents
and that actually is staffed by
well-qualified practitioners
um
but uh my concern and concern of others
is that you know is what the government
is proposing to invest in this system
will it address those different sides of
the court I mean I think you've raised
an interesting question because I mean
you know you're saying the Nordic system
is a generous system but but you know
it's been the way that it has been for
quite some time and therefore for the
vast majority of families it is the norm
and therefore they don't regard it as
general generous they disregard it as
what they expect
that's right but it's the same in
Germany which is a much more recent
change and the change of every child
from the age of one has a has a right to
a place has been from 2013 onwards and
it's interesting to watch what happens
there you know and that's largely
not-for-profit system because of course
the context of every system is different
but
um
I think my colleagues have just outlines
and Christine in particular all the
anomalies that still beset the current
system which are not going to be
resolved
it seems to me that the current systems
a long way from a universal entitlement
isn't it
doesn't work like that it's it allows
increasing social segregation you know
the children who only want it now we're
going to change that in 2025 or being
well uh who only wanted to 15 hours well
frankly in they go to the bottom of the
waiting list in many of the uh settings
where parents sign them up you know put
them on the waiting list because
um
understandable reasons but then we don't
deliver on the policy aims for putting
any public money in at all given the
current situation I mean I'm set
settings on on will naturally and
understandably in the financial
constraints look for the most lucrative
children from their perspective
absolutely and of course settings have
been cross-subsidizing and the
um social Enterprise that where I am
chair in Milton Keynes and in
surrounding counties
has that cross-subsidization model you
know where by having parents well-to-do
parents in Milton Keynes using
additional non-funded out IE additional
hours that if they're lucky they get a
tax-free child care for or you know we
can cross-subsidize those
um who only come for the 15 hours
or indeed some of them for the 20 hours
and that's that's is under threat with
the current proposals yes because at
this point Christine was making really
is that the current proposals as they
accept the government share of the
market they reduce the opportunities for
that cross subsidy absolutely and I
think I think to your point as well
there there is a huge opportunity cost
here there always is it's a very
complicated system we currently have
eight different programs to subsidize
child care we're now going to have nine
different programs to do that we know
that navigating that and making that
understandable to parents is important
and we've seen that really quite vividly
with the difficulties in take-up of
tax-free child care and Universal Credit
subsidies
um so I think you're not wrong to
suggest that complexity and
comprehensibility of the system is an
important parameter to think about when
we're designing this system but I wanted
to take this opportunity as well because
you asked more broadly about the
opportunity cost of this money and I
think it does come back to what it is
we're hoping to achieve I think the the
current sort 30 hour thing that's the
legacy of bolting on lots of different
entitlements to something that started
for Early Education that's not going to
be any anyone's idea of the perfect
answer to any of the questions that we
want our child care and earlier system
to achieve going more firmly down one of
those routes gives us more opportunity
to design something a bit more bespoke
but potentially at the cost of some of
the other outcomes I think what's most
important here is that we're setting
this in context of The Wider early year
system when we're thinking in particular
about Child Development some of the
programs that we've seen that have been
most successful for children's outcomes
in England have been things like
surestart children's centers or the
family nurse partnership in the earliest
years of life programs that involve you
know home visiting interacting with
parents and something that's very
intense not necessarily lasting for a
very long time and therefore not
necessarily particularly designed around
the idea of helping parents back into
work but that tool is still out there
and I think there's a risk that the
budget proposals continue quite a long
trend of the earlier sector becoming
ever more and ever more and ever more
about the free entitlement with much
less focus on things like tax-free child
care or Universal Credit which might be
more effective tools to support labor
Supply if we got them working well and
with much less focus on some of those
wider early years programs and
integrated earlier services that could
deliver better outcomes for children I
think one of the things that strikes me
though and you said you know that there
are eight different systems now soon to
become nine I mean and that's different
pots of money being spent in in
different ways if we were to put all of
that governmental money into one single
pot and design design one single system
might we get an overall better outcome
or is the Scott a gun approach
um you know
something that's going to better to be
developed or would be better starting
with a white blank sheet of paper
I think there's always a Temptation with
policy design to say let's start from a
blank sheet of paper because it makes
life easier we do have the system that
we have in front of us and I think one
thing I would be very much in favor of
is a wider ranging review to really
agree what it is we want this system to
deliver and use that to build towards a
Workforce plan a market plan a subsidy
plan how it is that we're going to get
there but I would also push back
slightly on the idea that you know the
the answer is going to be that we
agglomerate this pot of money and we do
one thing with it I think in practice
the aims of our earlier sectors are
diverse the policy goals we're trying to
achieve are different and so it makes
sense that the tools to achieve those
best will be different the challenges
getting those tools to work together I
mean yeah but you wouldn't necessarily
redesign a system which just does one
thing but what you could do is have a a
more comprehensive and in a linked set
of policies and which which sort of
dovetail more securely than the current
system absolutely and I think the the
sort of current system really is a set
of add-ons and bolt-ons and bits and
pieces that have been glued together
um which makes it much more complicated
than it needs to be for parents now I
apologize you may have already fleshed
this out but I mean the the ifs noted
that child care support is now largely
benefiting better off families is there
anything more that you wouldn't add to
that in in in terms of
um you know anything the government
could do to mitigate any potential
potential side effects so I think one
piece of that is is the design of the
budget proposals themselves um we reckon
that even even before anybody starts
taking up more child care at the moment
the expansion will directly benefit just
over half of parents with a child in
that nine month to two year age range
that's about one in five of families
that are jointly earning less than 20
000 pounds a year it's about four in
five of families that are jointly
earning more than 45 000 pounds per year
the fundamental question here is what it
is that we're trying to do with this
money if the people we're trying to
Target are the people with the highest
child care costs then yes by and large
those are the families with larger
earnings because you know being in
London or the southeast parents working
full-time professional jobs using quite
a lot of formal Child Care maybe they've
moved away from their parents and so
those informal options aren't there
those people tend to have high earnings
but also high costs if what we're trying
to do is really support child
development and think about the most
disadvantaged children at the bottom of
the distribution by construction these
budget proposals are really not about
doing that
thank you very much
you look over to Kim and if I can
encourage the panel to give clippy
answers so we can get to our next panel
that would be much appreciated and
um good morning panel I've got question
on the child care provider market and we
know that the market has been under
considerable pressure covert cost of
living you know 170 Child Care Centers
have closed with a loss of 10 000 child
care places and Professor Lloyd you
mentioned about the private profit
provision of child care and the fact
that so much profit is being extracted
from the sector so what extent do you
think that the private provision has led
to the inequality in the market between
disadvantaged and more affluent areas
well some of the the large corporations
haven't gone into the disadvantaged
areas at all but in the study that I did
with colleagues at the university
college and Penn and we did find a
fairly even distribution of for-profit
but it's smaller for profits in the
disadvantaged areas which of course have
been acquired and merged with and so on
at an alarming rate over the last few
years indeed and one of the results is
that we've had no increase in child care
places since 2015. so while all these
market dynamics are going on
um we're not really making things more
accessible or more affordable now one of
the interesting roles there that could
be enhanced is the role of opstead
because whereas we've got extremely good
statistics that the government can use
to look at the Early Education the
funded hours we've got very good
statistics actually our grip on what is
really going on in the CH on the child
care side in the private profit Market
is is pretty pretty light so we need to
know much more but of course ofsted who
are inspecting all provision
um do not collect a lot of development
information they don't collect the
information of whether a setting is is
freestanding so operator whether it's a
small chain whether it belongs off to a
chain that runs 300 settings it doesn't
look at the
salary structure
I mean it looks at whether the eyfs
ratios are met with the correctly
qualified but there are so many
questions we need we all need the
government needs to know the answers to
in order to be able to steer you know
Steer and shape that market
thank you Professor Lloyd um maybe my
next question to bagita and it's about
educational outcomes and I think you
know we've touched on the fact that um
the national Child Care strategy in 1998
was very much focused on
um the eradication of childhood poverty
so in terms of this um the budget
statement uh and where we're up to at
the moment you know will more regulation
in the child care market help address
the problems that we're now seeing
you mean in terms of child outcomes
whether it's more regulation is
recommended I think um a problem that I
I alluded to before is that it's very
hard um to find
um easily measurable indicators that
will tell you anything about the Child
Care Quality because
um teacher qualifications child to staff
ratios don't show such a clear relation
to the outcome and the more involved
measures like the echo scales that
measure are better measures of the
actual experience of children in
settings are very costly to collect and
and although offset has shortcomings and
we would like more information about the
settings in our research we find that
there are reports are related to child
outcomes with outstanding settings
delivering better outcomes in particular
for children from disadvantaged
backgrounds so
um I suppose regulating on the types of
things that ofsted measures would be A
Better Way Forward than um than just
teacher qualifications and and group
sizes
I don't think you alluded to earlier on
about how beneficial the likes of sure
start were in terms of improving
educational outcomes for children in
disadvantaged areas and I think that
subject to
um a wrap around care and the
integration of all those agencies do you
think that
um the government needs to be looking
more closely at how we look at
replicating some of the positives of
sure start going forward I mean
definitely this is research that is in
in Christine's area more than mine but
one thing I would say is that sure start
not only offers an integrated approach
but also these centers have been located
in the areas where they are within Prime
pushing distance of quite disadvantaged
families and and the focus on
disadvantaged families I'm sure is what
is part of the success but Christine
will know more I think that's right and
I think the integration point is very
important so we looked uh at first at
least at the health outcomes of children
and it's very difficult to pin that
directly back to a Health Service it
really seems to be something about the
wide-ranging package of services and
bringing all of that together which is
important
thank you um you mentioned how difficult
it is to quantify the quality of the
provision
um how much that reflected in the
qualifications of the early years
practitioners and the teachers should
they have you know GCSE maths and
English or should they have another sort
of training and actually be very
interesting to find out how that relates
to other countries as well and the
training they give at the early years
and the nursery teachers
would you like me to start thank you
yeah can I start with I would like to
start with a case study and that's a
case study about extreme deregulation
and that's the Netherlands
between 2005 and 2012. I closely
followed days but really we did uh pass
the Child Care Act in 2006 which was
really the promotion of the child care
Market give freedom to the providers to
um give in the Netherlands all the
um
supply side money was removed and all
the money was going to be demand side
subsidies to parents to to promote to
Market by you know shopping around
um the regulations were that group size
was relaxed ratios were relaxed we don't
actually have a restrict regulations on
group size we have them on ratios and
but we follow generally considered good
practice but in the Netherlands what we
what the decision was then to keep the
more highly qualified practitioners
you know because we all you know the
thought was they would be good for the
children well
the more highly qualified practitioners
on their you know on their own couldn't
really deliver the quality which was
already going down and the Netherlands
were lucky in that they have had a very
long
um longitudinal study that looks at
quality in daycare settings in group
settings every two years and the the
drop-off after this deregulation was
dramatic between 2005 so there had to be
a lot of rowing back on this and what
was once guidance was then changed into
enforceable regulations in terms of what
went on rather than telling the market
deliver responsible child care which was
the initial instruction
it was about but you you will also do
this and you will have you know
obviously a mix of qualifications so it
can be in fact and it wasn't just
self-interest that made the child care
sector in the Netherlands beg the
government for a covenant of some time a
kind to stop this this deregulation I
don't
agree with bigita about the the results
of the research I mean I think we have
some interesting findings on the result
for instance from the seed study here
you know we've got many good studies
funded by the government on what makes a
difference in terms of qualifications
which is a qualifications mix
and obviously graduates
um do make a difference if they have
sufficient practical experience you know
and they really know about the
challenges of working with young
children for long days in daycare but
also the other
different levels of qualifications are
important and it does worry me a good
deal that we really still we can work
with 50 of our staff in the settings not
having qualifications I mean this is
very much unlike the rest of Europe by
now yeah because it's not just about the
academic qualifications it's also about
pedagogy and and and child psychology
and all that sort of all these things
there's so many demands on the worker
yeah absolutely okay any other comments
on
whether they need GCSE nothing I'm just
interested in this point about GCC maths
in particular a lot of settings have
said to me you know we want people who
are well qualified to understand
children understand how to teach them
and so on so forth they recognize the
importance of English skills because you
need it for report writing and and and
Direction but there is a question about
yeah actually Beyond teaching number do
you really need GCSE maps in order to
work in a child care setting and it it
it seems a surprising requirement of
being able to take the level three
qualifications in some cases
I thought actually that was one of the
nastier comments in the otherwise
excellent not brown report in 2012
that's even for working in a Veterinary
practice you needed these qualifications
English and Massachusetts and you didn't
in early childhood and uh I was accused
of not taking uh you know the qual the
quality of the setting seriously if I
said I think we do need a gradual
Improvement and that's why it's so
important that we have proper continual
professional development it is just as
important as initial training
qualifications and because we it would
be unhelpful to have a total Revolution
although sometimes I'd like to see it
you know then these these gradual but
really gradual but steady
and we have been on Workforce strategies
on qualifications we've been Towing and
throwing and not really you know we had
a very good period with The Graduate
leader fund when it was Ring fenced
and we saw qualifications shooting up
and then when ring fencing was removed
in 2013 it really went down what
happened you know
okay thank you
thank you chair
um I I I just want want to start with
um a general question if I may because
uh it's it's we've just had the Easter
recess and this time of the year as
you're aware politicians are always
knocking on doors and this came out just
before just before Easter and I've been
very struck by the uh by the fact that
this is being welcomed by parents on the
doorstep but I'm going around nurseries
in my constituency of South and West as
part of this inquiry but I'm not getting
the same response from the nurseries
that I am visiting there's a lot of
concern about the the the inability to
cross subsidize
in the way they were doing previously
and real concern that big corporates
nurseries are going to be the ones to
survive and that the smaller not profit
and the smaller private nurseries which
are a converted house which are
providing you know fantastic care for
for young children are not going to
survive and I was reminded of what
happened you know by these nurseries
that I've been visiting I was reminded
of what what happened when the the eyfs
came in and was made statutory in 2008
and how that drove child minders out of
the market
um who didn't who didn't want to be part
of such a heavily regulated
sector and of course we've lost over 13
000 child minders in the five years from
2015 to 2020 so they're always
unintended consequences of reforms so do
you do you recognize the concerns of the
settings
uh absolutely I do and I think that goes
back to some of the very earliest points
that I made because this is such an
important point when you are buying 80
of the market getting that price right
is vitally important and so I think
settings are I can absolutely understand
where settings are coming from that
given the way that the funding rate for
existing entitlements has been developed
tinkered with Frozen in cash terms
eroded in real terms all of a sudden oh
maybe we should whack a couple hundred
million in and and boost that up a
little bit the the sort of piecemeal ad
hoc way that that's been managed I
completely understand why settings are
perhaps somewhat disinclined to trust
that the funding rates going forward
will be carried out in a more sensible
evidence-based consistent in way that
they're that they're able to anticipate
and act on and make sound business
decisions
um so I think one opportunity here is
that the government has given itself a
fair bit of lead time for implementing
these reforms I think that's quite
welcome that should allow for a lot of
Engagement with the sector it's perhaps
a bit of a shame some of that engagement
didn't happen before the budget
announcements were made but that that is
uh perhaps inevitable but making sure
that engagement happens and making sure
we get a proper process for setting the
funding rate I think will be crucial
that is another point that was made that
they weren't visited and asked their
opinions previously thank you that's
very helpful
um Professor Rabb
I don't think I have anything to add
thank you that's that's the perfect
answer as well
um Professor Lloyd thank you I think of
Ireland where there are a huge number of
child minders who have not been
regulated at all basically not wanting
to you know meet certain conditions so
only 75 child minders are the latest
count were registered out of fifteen
thousand or something so it's quite a
separate
um
part of the system now there is a
chart-minding development plan to be
carried out over six to eight years to
gradually bring child minders into the
orbit of the whole system with the group
alongside the groups you know and I
think that is very important not to have
these sharp demarcations if only for
safety reasons I I am I understand that
without mind is concern because they you
know
they have been on their own implementing
all this but
so there are models you know child
minding networks at one stage they were
supposed to be everywhere you know and
not just minding agencies yes I'm quite
uh unsure about child mining agencies or
you know apologies I was using that as
an example of the unintended
consequences and the real concern is
that big corporates will be the only
ones to survive and that we will lose a
lot of the smaller nurseries and the
not-for-profit nurseries that exist at
the moment that's the concern that was
that was right yes and I think people
are absolutely right and it will lead to
ever greater segregation and ever more
children losing out on having access to
provision at all because at the moment
there is no uh plan to expand Nursery
provision in schools but they could play
a very important role you know not you
know the 30 hours is still largely
delivered in the private sector so the
choices for children in low-income
families or families we have other
issues than low income but you know are
very limited it is an inequitable system
and the need to get hold of what is
happening in the in the private profit
large corporations which are very
insecure the research that I referred to
earlier that with the team from
University College and was Helen Penn
and Professor Atul Shah from City
University really found that the
um fragility of the large corporations
you know their lack of sustainability
they are indebted they're in hook to the
Syracuse that's wonderful but I must I
must ask another question
um that
um that I we need to ask
um this committee is visiting Finland
wonderful next next week in fact to
learn more about their child care system
as part of this inquiry so what do you
think we can learn from International
comparisons about the UK's relative High
child care costs are both from Finland
but also from elsewhere
so I think one of the things to learn
from International comparisons is comes
back to the aims of the system what
we've quite often seen is that in some
contexts like Canada which bird Gita
alluded to earlier we've seen systems
that are very very good at supporting
mothers into work but not so good and
perhaps even slightly detrimental in
terms of children's development
Scandinavian systems often lie at the
other end of that Spectrum they're
brilliant for children's development
they have long lasting benefits that
last all the way through middle age but
they did perhaps much less to support
parents and mothers into work so
designing a system with that clear aim
in mind and that clear goal in mind I
think is very important you also alluded
I think to the costs which I suspect was
a coded reference to getting into ratios
I think that is one place where England
is an outlier within Europe we have some
of the tightest ratios for particularly
the under twos but also for
two-year-olds even after the relaxation
announcement in the budget there are
vast difficulties in making those
International comparisons because of the
training of the workforce and all of
those other issues we've been speaking
about today but that is one place where
we stand out and as brigitta has
mentioned it's not always very clear
from the international evidence base how
much we can really say about how much
those ratios are driving the actual
process quality that children are
experiencing in the settings so I think
that's still a place where the evidence
is not yet quite conclusive thank you
it's very helpful
comparisons would be the way that
childcare is funded Ava has talked about
this the question whether we should have
the same support for families regardless
of their income I think is is is a
crucial decision to make
um I think Miriam Cates also asked what
you know what is the best use of our
money and where should we be
um
putting it and which families should
benefit the most I think these are
things that International comparisons
can be very informative about
thank you and may have come in on
Finland I've had the pleasure of
examining a PhD in Finland last so
summer and this study was part of a
concern amongst Finnish academics about
how whether the regulatory system they
have in place will protect the
universality of the surface they want to
offer to Children and Families because
Finland like Sweden has seen an enormous
growth of the private for profit
providers
so the same would you hear on the
doorstep
and this this is introducing
gently social segregation so really the
whole system is on the review it depends
on who you talk to but there are
stresses in that system there with
political change there was a very
sharp change to demand side funding to
promote the market in about 2016. that
has been reversed by Under the
government of Santa Marin who is no
longer the prime minister in Finland as
you will have noticed so there is some
touring and throwing between different
approaches to what creates most
provision and whether the Nordic model
is actually under threat
you mentioned also your work with
Ireland and obviously you mentioned
childbinders and anything else you'll be
useful for us to know about the
situation in Ireland because obviously
it is another English-speaking system
and it's always interesting to look at
what they do yeah it is a very young
system so in many ways they didn't
suffer from the past dependence that our
system suffers from you know we go back
to the 19th century with Early Education
and then it's much much later the child
care support public support but Ireland
um the funding model was
doubling the funding for the whole
system doubling the funding in over a
10-year period so that was the 2018
whole of government strategy first five
which was all the department all
relevant departments many together
producing you know this strategy wanting
every child to be able to benefit from
high quality child care and
the funding group the funding that
brought out recommendations to the
government on how to spend this double
the money
came up with as the very first
recommendation in fact all 25 were
accepted now being implemented this is
an unusual policy advise experience I
have to say and and the first one was
the workforce needs proper conditions
the workforce needs better pay and
therefore the government will pay core
funding alongside
a subsidy for Early Education and
subsidies to the parents for child care
and that core funding will have
conditions attached that core funding
will have conditions are touched about
what their staff should be paid because
unlike here there is no minimum pay
staff for as low paid as here and there
was a a long scientist there was a pro
program by the employment department for
actually setting a career structure in
place a legally enforceable structure
which is a major step and the other
important thing I think that Ireland did
was half of Workforce strategy
development plan at the same time
so in parallel
but and
agreeing that doing things this way
would require much more intensive public
management
Edward would require a closer
partnership between the government and
the private sector because Ireland
doesn't have a public sector for early
years provision there isn't one and
therefore you know
this required a change of mindset but
the fact that 9 out of 10 providers
signed up to this
suggests that it was an acceptable
compromise to lose some autonomy to
actually getting extra money and enough
to do more than raise the workforce pay
and improve their conditions and parents
yeah sorry again Kathy because her
petitions committee which she chairs has
been dealing with a number of um yeah so
and I mean you've raised a whole range
of points there and I think we just
haven't got time in this session to do
justice to the very rich evidence you've
given this morning so thank you
um but I wanted to touch very briefly on
two of the government's proposals and
that seek to address some of the
workforce issues so one being
um the promotion of increasing the
number of child minders and I know you
sort of briefly touched on that and and
sort of the incentivization payments for
people to sign up either as individual
child minders or with child care
agencies and to what extent you think
that will solve some of the workforce
issue issues and but then on the flip
side we have the ratio policy which
um I think the government's intention is
that it will reduce the cost of child
care and perhaps solve some of these
Workforce issues but some of the
evidence would suggest that it may have
the opposite effects I'd be really
interested to hear your views on to what
extent those two proposals from the
government are going to make the
situation better or potentially worse
so on the on the ratio's point I think
this as you say is was intended to ease
life a little bit for child care
providers with two-year-olds the first
thing to say is that many child care
providers looking after two-year-olds
already are not meeting those ratios so
the current ratios are not binding
um that limits the scope for the chain
for the regulation change to really
affect them I think that's about 20 of
two-year-old are are in settings where
those ratios are not currently binding
um I think the motivation very much was
around oh well we'll reduce the cost of
provision and that will reduce the cost
for parents I think it is plausible that
there will be some reduction at least in
the cost of provision there if you look
at the child care providers who are
bound by the current ratios Staffing
makes up about 75 percent of child care
providers costs so if you do want to
deliver a more efficient service you do
have to think about Staffing and given
that you can't really adjust child care
providers workers wages down anymore
because they're pretty much constrained
by the minimum wage ratios is really the
only game in town if you're looking to
reduce those Staffing costs but I think
the really important Point here is
around deliverability so the early years
Alliance and others have suggested that
many child care providers just sort of
don't want to touch this with a barge
pool they feel that their parents won't
like it won't want it won't sign up that
will obviously limit the real world
impact it has and the other piece that
will limit that is the is the market for
child care workers themselves if you're
making their job 25 harder than it is
right now and you're trying to do that
without increasing their wages because
you're trying to pass those cost savings
on to parents that strikes me as a
pretty difficult sell at a time when the
labor market in that Workforce is
already very tight and providers are
already struggling so much
um I mean do you want to comment on that
I would also ask and add to the question
because you say parents won't want that
for their children but there will be
some parents that have no choice and so
will we end up with perhaps
a lot of regional disparity in terms of
um quality of child care as a result of
some of the proposals where those who
can pay more end up with a higher
quality and those
um can end up with a more compromised
it's certainly in terms of ratios but
also in terms of quality and quality of
the workforce as well potentially
I think definitely we already have this
situation where the the families living
in the more deprived areas have acts
more rarely have access to settings
rated outstanding by ofsted we already
have that situation that the you know
the accessibility where you live is
limited and and the quality is quite
different so while we know that quite
disadvantaged families can you know gain
a lot by high quality child care they
just don't have the access and I think
you're right that um what we are going
to see is a larger disparity in the
offer through these kinds of steps yes
it is one of those areas where I think
it really could have very bad outcomes
for children with additional needs of
any kind because certainly after covet
we have seen this really increased need
for additional support for many children
children you wouldn't have expected now
if those additional support needs are
not to remain transient but you know you
know then we do have to put more support
in rather than less as far as the
workforce is concerned it is just one
other way of making them feel
undervalued you know because it is such
hard work to really be there with you
physically and emotionally and
intellectually responding to children in
a way that will promote their
development you know and so that what
we're asking them to do and then to say
well actually practical terms of course
a group cons the way that groups are
constituted fairies too I mean how do
you reduce the ratio for two-year-olds
who are in groups with smaller children
as well younger children or with older
children you know there's terribly
complex calculations which I know but
his interest
by and large you know that situation I
think should be left as it is did you
want to talk about child minders as well
I mean do you think the child minder
proposals and incentives will solve some
of these challenges
your new entrance to the child minding
market then you will need to probably
make changes to your garden or to your
kitchen or you know and they will easily
absorb the 600 pounds
I cannot foresee how the
um child minding agency's proposal could
you know would make an enormous
difference to a lot of child minders
immediately it's it's it's a
an anomalous proposal I think in terms
of and there's no evidence for it at the
moment yeah of what is being done what
can be done I mean there'll be some
agencies that that will will show that
they can support child minders very well
of course in the bus it's being seen in
the context of where you don't have to
be inspected by offset because you can
be inspected that was the original
proposal in 2013 you can be inspected by
the child minding agency which is into
it's not very clear but you know and
there's the scope of what's available is
not sufficient at the moment
thank you very much and we've overrun
with this panel but I think that's
because we've had some very rich and
interesting answers so I'm very grateful
um for that and grateful for the
patience and second panel if we can
bring up the second panel at this stage
and thank you very much for your
evidence
all welcome and thank you for sitting
patiently through the first session um I
I I I I I think we will
um ambitiously aim to wrap up shortly
after 12 o'clock um but um we may
require some fairly Snappy answers
um and and I hope the panel won't mind
if we spill slightly over that time in
order to um get the most um from the
second panel but I appreciate maybe
members who have commitments elsewhere
um from that time
um delighted to welcome Ian Mansfield
director of research head of education
and science of policy exchange
um uh Adam hawkesby deputy director of
onward and Dr Tammy Campbell the early
years lead at the education policy
Institute and thank you all for coming
to give evidence to us and
um you've heard some of the views
already expressed um if I can ask just
to start perhaps with uh looking at the
spring budget and what it did Cover but
also any areas that you feel uh from
your respective positions were missing
um from what could have been offered uh
to support the sector and to support
parents
um so yeah sort of our view is that the
the current plans in the budget are a
first step and it needs to be checked
and it needs to be honed and it needs to
be improved on
um we think that if this doesn't happen
as has been sort of touched upon in the
previous session and the current plans
risks giving the balance away from good
quality provision particularly for
disadvantaged to Children
um the first thing that we need to
happen that we've touched on a little
bit is that we think that the costings
and the assumptions in the budget for
both the additional payment for the
current entitlement and for the new
expanded 30 hours need to be made clear
and Justified and what we really don't
want is a repeat of the previous
expansion to 30 hours which was
underfunded which we know actually from
the earlier years alliances Freedom of
Information was knowingly underfunded
and which has had negative impacts on
the sector so we really think that the
onus right now is on the department on
the government to show the costings to
show the assumptions and to show that
this is going to be adequate adequate
for good quality not just for some kind
of sort of minimum floor standards
um
the other thing that we would like to
recommend is that funding is weighted
actually much more heavily towards
children from low-income families and
children with special educational needs
including disabilities
um because we know sort of from previous
sessions of this committee that there
are many disincentives
um to taking children who might need
more support and there are many gaps in
Access as has been talked about at
various points and one way that we would
like to recommend to do this is to
increase the earlier's people premium so
that it's in line with the pupil premium
in the later school years because we
have a dream situation at the moment
where the earlier people premium is just
342 pounds a year for Primary School
pupils it's
1455 pounds a year for secondary 1035
pounds so actually you kind of have
um almost this acknowledgment in the
sort of compulsory school system that
the younger children need more but then
for some reason that skews off um in the
early years and another thing that theme
we'd like to happen is to do with the
disability access fund so that is 800
pounds a year
but it's only available for children who
are in receipt of dla and getting dla is
extremely difficult it's very difficult
to apply for it's very difficult to be
awarded and so we really recommend that
the amount for disabled children is
raised and also that the eligibility
criteria to identify which children
would get more money under this criteria
um are revised
um one last thing we'd like to note in
terms of the budget which was touched
upon by colleagues in the previous
session and is that we think that sort
of um particularly given these existing
and continuing risks the earliest
provision that you heard about before
particularly for disadvantaged groups
and we think the budget as it's
currently formulated appears to be
rather short-termest
um
so even if we only care about the sort
of economic productivity side of things
which we don't but if we sort of take
that as its premise that that's what
it's focusing on
um you know the focus on kind of
short-term growth short-term increased
employment of parents of young children
um at the potential expense of quality
and access to Early Education this is
going to be counterproductive in the
long term because if children end up in
low quality early years provision or if
they can't access it and this is likely
to have long-term impacts on that
trajectory through education and their
future outcomes including employment and
learning so we think that policy should
be set up strategically for sort of
long-term success on whatever terms and
they're choosing to make themselves on
applying Anna's doorstep test I have to
say a lot of parents are saying this
look this feels quite long-term to them
because it's not coming into Force
immediately and the offers that they've
heard about aren't available yet so I I
think it's an interesting challenge
there but I recognize the point thank
you um I'll go over to Ian and then come
down thank you I think what I would say
is that we need to look at this through
the lens of access availability and
affordability for parents and what we
fundamentally have here is a supply side
issue we have over-regulated the market
we've driven over half of child minders
out of profession over the last decade
and this has driven up costs and it's
driven up and it's driven out access
particularly for parents who work you
know atypical hours in that light I
think the budget announcement is quite
similar to help to buy is perhaps the
best analogy it's an expensive demand
side subsidy which will cost a lot will
ameliorate some of the symptoms it will
help some families but it does nothing
to actually address the real underlying
supply side issues in the market
um I think the regulatory reforms which
proposed they're they're a good first
step I'm slightly alarmed that we
haven't seen any detailed papers on them
as the chair will know DFE published a
consultation on very similar measures
last summer last June I believe and
nothing has come out of that and it
seems it's easier to make spending
commitments than it is to actually
address regulatory reform that being
said if we can bring forward those on
child minders and ratios it would be a
good first step however I would say we
need to go much much further in looking
at the burden of the eyfs in particular
and at all the burdens which the state
is putting in the place of parents being
able to leave their children with who
they wish other than safeguarding
principles which of course should not be
compromised and obviously apply to other
settings such as Scouts guides tutors
and so forth we should really look at
just allowing those who wish to get into
the market to offer child care to do so
and to allow parents to be the judge of
where they would put their children and
this will have tremendous benefits both
with the availability of children and
we've heard that it's often those in
disadvantaged families who have least
access to child care and in terms of
getting people back into the labor force
okay thank you Adam
so I think firstly just to say that we
were delighted that childcare had such a
big place in a fiscal statement I mean
there are lots of problems with an
issues to be addressed in what was
announced but the fact that struggling
families that the cost of parents that
the lack of provision was at the
centerpiece of uh that statement a very
difficult fiscal moment I think is a
real positive and it's a testament to a
lot of the people that have given
evidence to this committee and members
of parliament that have championed it
the unusual thing
um particularly for the treasury seems
to be that they've gone big with the
financing and the funding uh the kind of
harder bit arguably certainly
politically
um without doing some of the uh easier
stuff not easy but comparatively some of
the stuff that could be done on the
provider side I think is quite
straightforward it's quite concrete and
quite clear and so that's where I think
the biggest focus is now uh required I
agree with a lot of the comments that
have come previously we need to improve
the skill levels and the professional
development in the workforce we need to
unlock the potentials of intermediaries
like child minder age agencies to make
some aspects of the market work and I
agree we need to streamline regulation
as part of a balanced set of reforms
that agree with the comments on the eyfs
I think there are two other things we
need to do though on top of that broad
focus on quality and on skills one some
ambition from all parties on a more
radical overhaul of the system of Mr
Moon's raised a very valid question
about whether we want to move to eight
nine we want to move to a more
simplified system on would have made
clear that moving towards a system of
child care credits a simplified upfront
system paid monthly that removes a range
of these different entitlements would be
the way they to go into Ian's point
would support a more Dynamic Market as a
form of subsidy but the second to the
questions that Mrs Cates was Raising
earlier is around increasing choice for
those parents that do want to stay at
home and we have three ideas in our
paper around front loading child benefit
around a new approach to parental leave
and around the expansion of family hubs
so I can chat about all of those in more
detail but there are some real practical
things the government can do that
ensures that they're not that they're
getting the most out of the investment
that they've announced yeah and I think
we will come back to some of that uh I I
I I think in particular part of the
challenge is from a DFE perspective some
of that policy obviously Falls outside
of the DFE remix but I think it is part
of the the challenge of looking at this
as a whole
um and uh I I I I will
um I guess we heard the debate earlier
as well about the balance between Child
Development educational outcomes and
Workforce outcomes um do you have a view
as you know individually or collectively
as to you know if if the approach in the
budget which we've heard was very
heavily focused on the workforce
outcomes of this
um is that missing the point is that
um you know right but only in part
um and and how do we balance those I
mean I've always taken the view in
arguing for investment in this space
um that actually they need not
necessarily be opposed to one another
they can be complementary but I think it
is um how do we make sure we're striking
the right balance between those three
um yes so I mean I agree with you that
they don't need to be in conflict
because if we properly fund the system
if we have a good Workforce if it's an
attractive profession to work in if we
have as was mentioned before sort of
child care providers earlier chain
providers that parents actually want to
have their children in and as people
said before if the counterfactual of
going there for some time is
enhances the child's life then the
parent can go to work and the child can
have a great experience and this is all
going to go in the same direction the
problem right now is that the
indications are well we already know the
sector's underfunded we already know
that we've got the workforce crisis and
so on
um the really fundamental thing I think
that we need is proper as I said before
sort of properly costed adequate and I
again when I say adequate I mean to get
that level of quality to get somewhere
that parents want their children to go
we need that funding fundamentally
that's the first thing and then
everything can work in Harmony and it it
is more than it says in the budget it is
more money but I don't think this is
something we should apologize for
advocating for it's somewhere that's
worth spending money
yeah
um I'd very much agree with you uh um
chair that these don't have to be in
Conflict at all
um they can very much work in tandem I
think there's a couple of things I'd
like to bring out is that there's a lot
of focus which is rightly placed on the
quality of the actual Child Care
settings but we don't look enough at the
cost and of to Children of those not
being available in the first place and
in a sense what we've done by driving
out flexible options by driving out
child minders it's similar to what you
see in very highly regulated labor
markets you see there that if you have a
very highly regulated labor market you
will have some who happen to have the
you know that get the prime contracts
which are regulated who have very good
conditions you'll have many others who
are on short-term catalyzed contracts
you have no rights at all by insisting
on high numbers of regulations very
tight ratios very disproportionate
ratios compared to the rest of the
developed World by imposing the eyfs
which since 2008 has driven out I say
over half of child minders
um since then almost half in the last
decade what we have done is we've
significantly reduced the availability
of any sort of child care at all which
is particularly hitting those from
disadvantaged backgrounds and if they're
not getting any child care at all that
is actually worse than them getting what
would be a perfectly good level of child
care which existed pre-2008 and which
many parents were very very happy with
of course we don't we talk about minimum
standards and so forth but actually
there's very little evidence if you look
at research from Canada if you look at
research in Australia from the US that
many of the things that we have imposed
on the system are doing anything to
actually meaningfully drive up quality
and in some cases such as ratios they
may actually be driving down quality
because they prevent us from paying the
work for course in the way that would
attract the best people
and I would agree with much as what's
been said I think the way that you can
square the circle is by emphasizing
include prioritizing parent choice and
so I can understand why in a fiscal
statement in which one of the big
challenges was Labor Supply you'd focus
on the labor participation side of the
coin you also have huge challenges in
this country with family breakdown with
the psychosocial development of young
people and so I'd understand why in a
future kind of fiscal statement or
announcement it may well be that there
are other elements that I mentioned kind
of child benefit parental leave that
might support different cohort of
parents but there are clearly strong
preferences by some parents that would
like to spend more time at home and
others that would like to go into work
if they could and we need sometimes
different policies for both of those
alongside broader reforms to a market
thank you for bringing Kathy thank you I
mean ratios is an issue that the
petition committee has looked at because
we had a very large petition signed
um in support of the Oliver steeper
family who very tragically lost their
child at nursery and are very
um Fierce campaigners for reducing the
ratios further um on the basis that it
has been expressed by child care
providers that and it was in the
department for education's 2022 report
on the early years Workforce that
practitioners were concerned about the
changes possible changes to child ratios
viewing it as an unsuitable approach
that could impact on the quality of
child care provision and increase
workload and dissatisfaction among staff
and I appreciate
um you know policy exchange has a
different View and you've already
expressed what you see is some of the
potential advantages but how do you deal
with the the Viewpoint from Child Care
Providers themselves that they see this
as a backward step I would say the only
is on them to provide an iota of
evidence that the Child Care Systems in
Australia in Canada in France in
Scotland in a host of other developed
countries are somehow inadequate for
this which they failed to do I think the
the evidence is that the qualification
requirements are very different in those
countries and that evidence clear
um qualifications can make a difference
that's certainly true although they do
vary quite widely between those
countries ultimately this is about
parental choice if parents want to put
their children into it to choose you
know a place which has smaller number of
ratios they would be able to do so would
you honestly believe parents have a
choice over where they all parents have
a choice ever where where they put their
children and what ratios they may be
within that child care setting well
right now they certainly don't because
the places don't exist because we've
regulated the amount of existence
uh amending child staff ratios will um
impact on costs have a positive impact
on cost and I think it might have a
negative impact on quality three quick
things so one the point on the other
qualification of the workforce I think
that Canon should be addressed so we can
talk later about ways that you might
upskill but until you have it seems odd
to me that you'd relax the ratios and
then do the upskilling work as opposed
to
um sequencing things the other way
around secondly
um I agree with the comments made by the
ifs previously that there's little
evidence that the binding constraint for
two-year-olds is ratios and actually
there is a binding constraint of space
and so I think many um child minders or
sorry formal Child Care settings that
wanted to take advantage of ratios would
have to increase their premises I think
very few in the financial position to do
so but the third thing is parents I
think you know Ian's right the parental
choice is a big element of this we
polled 10 policies with parents when we
did our report there was only one of
those that had net opposition and that
was a relaxing of child care ratios even
when we included in the question in line
with other countries 52 of parents
oppose 27 in favor and that makes sense
you know when you talk to parents when
they tour formal Child Care settings
they very rarely say oh the main thing
that I'd like here is less supervision
and more kids right and when we polled
uh actually the very top thing that
parents wanted was staff being trained
to a higher standard that was 59 of
parents and that was above costs being
low which is 39 and hours being flexible
35 so actually what parents want is
highly trained members of Staff if we
get there maybe we relax ratios but but
I don't think it's the top policy
priority
uh yeah just on this point about the
sort of um them being regulated out of
loosening ratios actually in the current
framework there is
um a um line that says you can actually
not adhere to these ratios if you can
show that it's not detrimental and there
is some evidence from the dfe's stats
and surveys on this that actually some
providers do already do this but from
the same research from the DFE and the
indications are that most providers in
line with this don't want to do it
because they care about the quality
providing and they know that it's not
attractive to parents and what's also
really worrying though actually on the
sort of flip side of that in the dfe's
um survey on this accompanying all of
this going on is that I think it was 28
of providers said they would change
provision in response to ratios most of
them said they would reduce Staffing
most said they would not pass savings to
parents and most said that they would
Implement these changes to support
Financial sustainability so they're kind
of being forced into this situation as a
kind of like Last Resort
um option that's not going to improve
things for anyone and the dangerous was
sort of talked about in the previous
session of this committee is that we
developed this two-tier system because
yeah parents are not actively going to
choose they're not going to go somewhere
and go oh I want the police with fewer
staff it's going to be the people who
don't have other choices who go to the
places with fewer staff we see that
throughout the education system that the
people who can make choices who can
afford to make choices do those who are
constrained don't and that will be the
outcome that it will push towards kind
of more diversity of quality he wanted
to come in quickly on this one just
quickly as well I mean I think I've
listened to quite a number of elements
of evidence given there was there's a
great deal of concern amongst the
workforce themselves about increasing
child uh child issues I mean because you
know the bottom Lane is one day you know
each individual member of staff is
responsible for four children and then
the next data may be responsible for 25
more than okay it's only one more tail
but it's a lot over a day over a week
over a month you know it's an awful lot
of additional responsibility and an
awful lot of additional activity for for
many staff who were already feeling the
strain frankly
in England and so this is one of the
reasons that the international
comparisons are not particularly useful
because we have this sort of crisis in
terms of recruitment retention staff
turnover so in Epi research by our
previous earliest lead cerebronati I
think it was nearly 40 percent
of Staff in early as providers leave
within two years and that means that
you have so if we change ratios it's in
a context where we have a turnover of
staff so maybe if you're in a country
where you've got sort of a very stable
qualified staff they know the children
really well the children know them
really well they're consistently there
every day maybe you can tweak the ratios
a bit but in the context where there's
so much else that's going on that's weak
within the system weakening another part
doesn't make sense very quick right of
reply for you yeah you said you'd we're
looking after 25 more children that also
means you're getting 25 more funding and
that funding yes some of it could go to
parents but some of it could also be
reinvested in the nursery in quality and
qualified staff
um
in terms of the proposals we heard some
skepticism from the previous panel
around the proposals for child minders
um in the budget proposal I know both
Ian and Adam you've talked about the
importance of that market do you have a
view on how the government's proposals
in the budget will help to to allow
child minders to meet for demand but we
expect to see from 30 hours policy but
also around the role of agencies and
perhaps invite you to explain if you do
disagree while you do disagree with the
comments we heard earlier about the role
of agencies yeah so I think I think the
the things on child mind is a positive
if if they do appear and um a good first
step they could go further
um fundamentally and I'll address the
thing of agencies first so the idea of
agencies is that because we have placed
so much regulatory burden upon child
minders that agencies can act as an
intermediary they can act as um
you know as essentially a broker who can
handle much of that can support child
minders they would obviously be a
competitive Marketplace
um those who weren't effective at
supporting child minders would find it
hard to recruit other child minders
those who were successful would move
forward it feels that if we are going to
insist on a system where we have this
level of Regulation then child mind
agencies can be very helpful in that in
that role in terms of Bridging the Gap I
would say we can go further in terms of
just simply reducing the regulation full
stop and it's something which we should
look at though isn't enough in the
government's proposal on the eyfs for
example and that is somewhere where they
could be significantly more more
positively I think some of the more
technical rules about where the child
mind his own children count against the
ratios are very positive I think this
will help with flexibility I think
there's a lot of little bits of detail
in there which will not make if they're
not transformative but they're good
things to do and the government should
be commended for them I'd like to just
put out two further things one I do
agree with the previous speaker who
indicated they thought 600 pounds
probably wasn't enough to make a
difference it may help some of the
margins but I think we need to look more
at you know improving the basic
conditions of work which means reducing
that regulation increasing access and
availability rather than sort of a
one-off payment to that
um I wouldn't say no to it but it's
probably not the best use of money and
then the third one is there's a proposal
that we made in our
a recent paper which was allowing child
minders to work outside the family home
this was done in France and they've
already had in the four years since it
was introduced they've had 4 000 child
minders move into this space and
um more indicating they have interest
what this means is that people who want
to be child minders but perhaps their
own home isn't suitable for it could
work in other premises that could be
Church Halls that could be schools who
want to use them to provide wrap around
care again it's just increasing the
availability and putting more options
for Parental choice and that's something
which we think could have significant
impact there
thank you I'm very supportive of the
role that child minders
um can play they offer this kind of high
quality flexible provision the really
unusual thing is the hierarchy in the
mind of parents seems to be private
nurseries are much much more preferable
to child minus about 46 of parents said
that if Money Was No Object they'd use a
private Nursery about 22 a child minder
but weirdly child minders are the more
expensive of the two options right the
market hasn't responded to those signals
the child might have about 83 quid a
week compared to about 76 for a day
Nursery so I do think there's a big role
here in increasing Supply I think child
monitor agencies have a major role to
play I was very pleased that there was
that difference in the bonus no 1200
versus 600 I'm similarly skeptical that
that will persuade someone to change
career or start a new career but you
know to step in the right direction but
I think we need to change some of the
regulations around CMA so a few things
one there's this imbalance in the system
currently offsted get a thousand pounds
per register child mind there but a
similar bonus doesn't go to a CMAs that
puts them in this weird competitive
position with both their regulator
ofsted in regulating CMAs and Regulators
for the broader industry so there needs
to be recommended in our paper at 700
pound or a thousand pound bonus that
goes to CMAs for everyone they sign up
the same as ofsted would get and that
might even help to lower some of the
registration costs they see
um secondly we do need to reduce some of
the regulatory burden on child minders
things like GP checks that I think are
unnecessary and thirdly we need to do
something about landlords and how they
interact with child minders so evidence
seems to be from providers and child
minor agencies a significant number of
job miners going out to business is due
to landlords changing the terms of that
license and often these are these
animals are local authorities so you
have local authorities that with one arm
of their organization are very
frustrated a lack of child care
provision and with another arm that I
doubt is talking and to the other part
of the organization are shutting them
down so a bit more joined up thinking to
ensure that um
ministers about that particular issue
particularly with registered social
landlords it does seem extraordinary but
so many of them ban people from doing
child minding when it is clearly a
social benefit to have it there so yeah
that strikes me as something that does
need fixing
um but uh but no that's an interesting
one uh sorry Tammy do you want to come
in on this as well on the the role of
child minders and perhaps um so you
might have a different view about the
the eyfs
um yeah so I can talk more about the
eyfs side of things in terms of the sort
of the payment I agree it doesn't seem
very much in terms of the child mind
their agencies I agree with you for on
the previous panel that it's not very
transparent what's going on and the
evidence on them and sort of why this
would be beneficial so I'd like to know
more about that so we can consider it
um yeah in terms of the eyfs
um so the the kiwis and well one of the
key reasons that it was developed and
put in place was to ensure that all
children receive sort of consistent
Education and Care and attention to
their development
um regardless of the type of setting
that they attend
um so that we don't think that
differentiating the framework
um according to setting type is a good
idea because it could risk a lessening
of knowledge of what to expect and ways
to support children among settings not
using the framework or using a different
framework however saying that
um
we do acknowledge the points about the
sort of burden of bureaucracy and
paperwork and so on and actually that
plays not only to child minders that
applies to other types of settings as
well and I know that in the um 2021
framework it does explicitly state in
more than one place that excessive
bureaucratic documentation and recording
of children's progress is not required
um and I think this doesn't respond to
response to concerns raised about too
much paperwork and bureaucracy
um and obviously this links to later
education as well there's all sorts of
issues around sort of accountability and
paperwork and the um workload
issues with that for teachers and so we
think that there are there is some scope
for revision here in terms of kind of
making the framework work in a way that
is actually helpful for children and for
people working with children and I'm
using some bureaucratic burden and we
think it'd be worth clarifying how
exactly um the framework applies to the
pre-reception years as opposed to the
reception years because most of the bits
on bureaucracy seem to be kind of more
applicable to reception Baseline and
Foundation stage profile assessments and
it's not really clear what the
implications are if they intend to
lessen the burden for people working in
the early years so we think that that
could be improved
um yeah as I said we need to make sure
that there's not sort of excessive
bureaucratic paperwork and documentation
it takes away from work with children
rather than facilitating it and we need
to make sure that it's not seen as
necessary by practitioners if it's not
necessary or required by Regulators
including ofsted and that it's not
perceived as being required by ofsted
that you have a room of paperwork to
show them
um if the of them will often say that
there's a lot of perception around the
records need to be kept which isn't
always the case and it is one of the
constant challenges I know across the
beat
um is trying to mythbust sometimes on on
some of the records that do need to be
kept versus those but actually don't
yeah but then the question is sort of
like you might have that said at the
sort of high policy level but what's
actually happening in practice when
people are going into settings is it
just that settings have a misconception
or in practice are they still being
expected to show a lot so there's
something to be done there definitely
thank you
um I will bring in Miriam
um
the treasury seems to be very confused
about what they actually want from the
this policy because on the one hand most
The Narrative around the budget was
about increasing parents participation
in the workforce particularly mothers
and yet even their own figures suggest
that only around 60 000 parents May
return to work in some capacity as a
result of the
um changes when I asked a written
parliamentary question to the treasury
about whether they've considered a more
flexible use of the money so to support
people who want to stay at home to
support people using their vouchers to
pay informal child care to make it more
flexible the reply was no we can't do
that because we want quality education
for children which seems a completely
mixed message because if you want
quality education for children that's an
entirely different aim to trying to get
mothers back into workplace they may be
mutual mutually achievable but it's a
different Aim so what do you see what is
quality early years education because
other countries start formal education
much later and yet have better outcomes
so what do you think these outcomes are
that the treasury is looking for from
quality Early Education I mean I presume
they're looking at the sort of
productivity side of things and actually
you know there are nuances but the
evidence is pretty clear that if you
have good education and this comes down
to the workforce it comes down but it
comes down to the detail of things it's
the interactions with children it's the
attachment it's the attention it's the
ability of
um staff you know to pick up special
education on these and disabilities and
to help children and to work with
families that if you have all of these
things then yes it could be for your
well-being it can set you up well for
school and that carries through and
um I presume that's kind of the basis of
what they are
thinking about but I agree with you that
things are not very coherent at the
moment and I think this um this comes
back to what Christina said before about
we've got these two with these different
policy areas kind of working around and
in interaction with each other but we
don't have a sort of proper strategy or
proper premises in terms of what we're
trying to achieve and we need to be a
lot clearer and I think it comes back to
the question before about do these
things need to be in Conflict yeah does
there need to be a conflict between the
kind of economic productivity angle and
the sort of child well-being
um support for family support for
parents angle and actually you know that
doesn't yeah there is actually a fairly
simple solution here of having a
properly funded system that parents
would choose to send their children to
and that they would be happy to do that
and they would take advantage of the
positives of working that some of them
would choose to take advantages of the
positive of working a net that would
work kind of quite well yeah Ian you
talked about the bureaucracy of early
years childcare and one of the barriers
to the child minders is not actually
necessarily the low wages although I'm
sure that is the case but of the
bureaucracy of having to fill in forms
and register with offsted and all those
kind of things do you think that'd be
our bureaucracy adds to the quality of
early years care and education what we
do to increase the quality yeah so no no
I don't and I think I think there's a
couple things I I would disagree I would
disagree with um my sort of co-witness
here a little bit on a couple of things
so I think there's a lot of reference to
properly funded child
um child child care I think we do need
to get away from a system which is you
know from a mindset which is only about
the taxpayer putting in more money into
formal settings and I think this that
underlies the assumption that there is a
limitless pot
um to subsidize Child Care sort of
underlies a lot of what's been said it
said to this committee now I'm not
saying it's not worth investing it in it
is
um the other area I'd push back there
against is against the treasury because
they say their whole thing of we want a
quality Child Care against suggesting
what had informal options it's very much
a state knows best
um I don't believe that's true I think
parents know best and if they choose
that their child would be better in an
informal setting with a grandparent
perhaps with another setting in a more
informal setting or in a state Nursery
which is absolutely fine as well all
being looked after at home by the
parents that is actually ultimately
their choice to make and actually what
we've seen through our
over focus on trying to achieve quality
through regulation is we've created a
crisis we have 70 000 more places today
if we hadn't driven all those child
minders out of the system actually if we
were looking at more radical overhauls
moving to a system of much more
flexibility potentially vouchers but in
which parents could use those to pay in
a much wider variety of settings without
the state control basic safeguarding
checks of course or indeed direct
payments to parents which we see more of
in France and in Canada so they could
choose to stay at home or to pay for
child care alongside with a relaxation
on the unnecessary regulation would
actually increase affordability access
and availability and those three watch
words they are not
how I'll be honest they're not how the
department for Education thinks of it
they don't see it as a crisis that we've
lost 70 000 places as long as the
quality the perceived quality based on
certain Frameworks of the places that
still exist is there that's all that
matters but we don't think about the
places that we've lost and the places in
informal settings and with relatives
that could be made available under a
more flexible system because you said
earlier that
government has totally over regulated
this labor market and one of our earlier
Witnesses said that if this policy is
fully rolled out eighty percent of the
available Child Care hours will be
bought by the state so essentially the
state will have nationalized the means
of production and the catastrophe that
that will then bring for the market is
well I think you then have a you do have
a real concern of the state setting
prices and if the state sets the price
too low then availability could really
fall dramatically here I'm sorry to come
back to the analogy of housing again but
housing and child care
um other than the recent energy crisis
which is hopefully a short-term thing
but housing and child care probably the
two biggest areas where costs have risen
much first faster than inflation and
that make a real impact on the household
budget of almost every family in the
country and by housing I'm including
both rental and mortgage costs
if you look at both those markets what
do they have in common they have massive
extensive government regulation which is
massively restricted supply has driven
up demand and has not really made
anywhere any commensurate increase in
quality and I think the solution is
obvious it's for the state to provide
subsidies or support yes support in
terms of vouchers in terms of direct
Supply or in terms of help which I'll
get not against those but to get out of
regulating the supply at least certainly
not get out it may be too strong to
significantly step back from it and
allow the market to provide the services
that in this case that parents want
thank you and Adam from your point of
view what does quality early years
education look like or should we be
talking about care rather than education
so I think so to step back a little bit
and then come to your question so I
think there's lots and lots of good
evidence that the state and developed
Nation should be investing far more in
children at the age of zero to two in a
variety of different ways I'm pleased
that MPS like Andrew ledson have been
kind of banging the drama and making
that case oh development was it both
Child Development is the main issue
isn't it really
um yes in a broad sense right and so
that would be the development that they
can get in a family in a home setting in
the development there as well as in a
formal setting as well as an interaction
um with others I think
in terms of what quality provision looks
like I think there are there is good
evidence that between kind of zero to
one that there is an emphasis towards a
home care setting that there is a
benefit to children being in the home
and that from one to four there's a
benefit depending on the Parents Choice
in the particular instance and I agree
with the evidence uh given in the
previous session that a lot of this
depends on both the quality of care in a
formal setting and the quality of care
and provided in a home with some sort of
mix and balance is right I think the
really important thing about what the
treasury's objective is here and this
gets lost I think sometimes in the
communications that they put out either
publicly or in the house are that there
are three cohorts that need to be
affected by this policy one parents who
want to work but can't and I believe
there's a significant number of those
and secondly parents that are working
but are really struggling because of the
cost of child care and third parents
that aren't working and would rather not
and would like support to work from home
I think both of those first two groups
carry an enormous amount about the
quality of formal provision whether
that's feeling comfortable dropping
their kid off in the morning or feeling
confident
decision to take up these subsidies and
I think that's why we need more provider
site reforms to increase that quality
and I was pleased that we saw the
announcements we did it's that third
cohort parents that actually would
rather not
um put their child into a formal setting
early that's why we need some more
policies what does quality Child Care
look like particularly for young under
threes because at the end of previous
panel so there's not an awful lot of
evidence for you know what's good and
bad for under threes I mean is it every
child care worker has a GCSE is it a
nice room that's heated you know is it
that they're learning phonics from the
age of six months I mean what does it
actually you know what's the researcher
says what is quality care and quality
Child Care from naught to three do we
know so I think we do know on some of
those aspects and the kind of the
academics of the evidence in the
previous session will know some of this
better than me we do have good evidence
that graduates being present in these
settings is a benefit we do have
evidence about what the public realm and
the physical setting needs to be like we
do have good evidence about the level of
qualification how that relates to ratios
have we had a proper conversation about
how all of that comes together and
therefore given the state is now
investing as the ifs said in the last
session about double the amount they
were previously are we really clear
about what we want this to achieve
possibly not and that's one of the
reasons I'm actually Keen for ofsted
maybe to move away from the very
significant role they have in job minor
regulation because actually by stepping
back from some of the micromanagement
they can step into a conversation about
quality and actually one of the things I
want to be cautious about is yes ofsted
in the state where we need to step back
from micromanagement regulation but I
don't think they need to step back
altogether they need to lean in I'm
taking from a DFE perspective need to
lean into the upskilling and the
training side of things far more and I
hope we can talk about that in in a
moment thank you
okay I'll bring in Kim thanks
um we heard from the first panel this
morning about the media disparities in
the quality of care for children you
know from disadvantaged and diverse
communities or who have a special
educational need so Tammy can you say
what you think is necessary to address
these inequalities in Early Education
and do you think that quality can be
improved when so much profit is
attracted from the sector and not
invested in wages and training yeah I
mean this comes back to sort of what I
said um in the initial response to the
budget really
um I do think that
there's and both from an economic point
of view and from a sort of ideological
point of view to be honest there is an
onus to provide
um to make sure that um children in
poverty children with disabilities
children from other disadvantaged
backgrounds including children in care
and so on can access good quality Early
Education and I was going to come in on
the quality question because we've still
got fuzzy definitions here but I think
we do actually know quite a lot about
what that is but that's a separate
question and but it comes back to sort
of the recommendations that I made
before I think that um
given the market we need to incentivize
providers to take children
um who might need more resources so we
need a much more heavily weighted early
as people premium we need a much more
heavily weighted disability access fund
with with less onerous
demands to get it because it doesn't
really work right now
um and I think this comes back to the
question of whether the state should be
funding this and I think that the we
can't just leave it to the market we do
need to
have the state ensure that there is a
parity of provision across people groups
and across areas so that I mean at the
moment sort of core rooms later survey
for this year found what the sort of
over 80 percent of local authorities
said they didn't have sufficient
provision for children with disabilities
and that's just shocking you know that
the budget is now looking at expanding
things to subsidize more Advantage
children of working parents essentially
what did Christina say before sort of 80
of it is just going to be a subsidy
we've got more sort of pressing crucial
things going on here more sort of
massively unmet needs that I think we
need to be looking at first so I'm not
sure if that answered your question how
do you think that happened given that
we've got also crisis in terms of
Workforce you know the training and
retention of Staff within the sector
um currently because you know the the
pay and the value of the web that's
undertaken as seen
um so negatively this moment in time
yeah I mean I think again I I basically
sounding sort of record is I think that
effect it needs to be paid better so as
you know sort of various stats including
us at Epi show that sort of nearly half
of the earliest Workforce claimed in
what benefits due to low pay and we've
also got some research Again by sorry
but not your previous early years lead
which really showed the kind of thin
edge of the wedge here so 13 of the
workforce earn less than five pounds an
hour and you know the average wage
across the earlier's workforce is seven
pound forty two an hour and that
compares to 12.57 for the total
population so it's not an attractive
profession if you need money which we do
we need when we're working we need to be
paid adequately and we want to attract
people in and have it be an attractive
profession so again it comes back to
funding and not sort of putting the
sector on the back foot by underfunding
the funded hours if you're going to roll
out the extended 30 hours then do it
properly so that sectors so that the
sector isn't that sort of a loss and
having to cross subsidized and so on
um and again this comes down to this
sort of relates to the sort of Staff
training and development as well so
making sure that sort of and the ratios
as well related to this making sure that
there's um enough time and money and
stuff so that staff can develop and
train involve because again that makes
it more attractive and it's good for
children and we think that it's also
um worth looking at introducing more
parity with um later education stages in
terms of um the structure of sort of
different qualifications and routes
within the earlier's workforce
um
not things like the ECF and mpus which
are available in other robots of
Education yes possibly I mean there's
sort of there's lots of ways to have
career paths and progression aren't
there and we definitely think that's
um worth looking at and it's worth sort
of looking back at sort of you know the
past decades so I think it was Eve from
the previous panel mentioned
um The Graduate leader fund and how that
worked and it was embedded in this wider
Workforce strategy
um and there were again it comes back to
this kind of not having proper
strategies not having proper policies
with a with a specific focus and that
had this specific focus it had ring
fence funding and it saw
um the qualification levels not just
more graduates but more level threes
happened under that strategy
um and then that finished then instead
we had um this was asked about before I
think we had the GCSE requirements come
in instead and they don't seem to have
had a helpful effect
um the workforce is has de-skilled after
they were introduced and so I think we
need to look really carefully at sort of
what qualifications or types of
qualifications or content of
qualifications is actually useful what
training and development is actually
useful not just box ticking
um and what mix within settings is
useful and what's useful for the leaders
as opposed to the ground level staff
sorry I felt like I went on a bit of a
tangent with that for example um can I
bring in Andrew and actually just on
this point of qualifications and the mix
we've heard a lot about the mix in in
that respect a lot of Nursery leaders
practitioners will have said to me is
that yeah actually a qualification
doesn't necessarily Define how well
someone will work for children you can
have people who are experienced in
working with children who have no
qualifications whatsoever but who
provide a really valuable contribution
as long as they are part of that overall
mix how can you design a system to
perhaps recognize that
um yeah I mean so if we think that the
system should definitely recognize that
um I don't think we can we don't have
good kind of national quantitative
evidence on what the optimal mix is
right now and that's kind of what we
want for National policy making so if
we're doing things at that level I think
that one thing that we'd recommend is
the um firstly we should sort of review
systematically the evidence on this and
then we should maybe pilot
um and evaluate different sort of
because we don't know enough we should
actually do some experiments with this
let's look at sort of what mixers work
well for children in terms of the kind
of the types of qualifications and
experience
of staff and that would include you know
sorry am I overrunning I was quick
quickly coming on that and then go to
Andrew sorry I think it's really
important to focus on flows as well as
stocks so I am nervous and worried about
the level of qualifications there are in
the workforce I'm particularly nervous
about the number of people that are
participating in training while they're
in work right so we've seen that the
proportion of people studying towards a
higher qualification fell by about a
third between 2008 and 2018 about 23 to
15 17 of the early years Workforce are
receiving job related training so I
think the real thing we need to focus on
instead of how many at the point they're
trying to access
qualification is how can we maximize the
number that are working towards some
kind of formal qualification or
participating in professional
development if I could just pepper five
things that I think you guys should be
thinking about in terms of policies one
getting more graduates into the
workforce via a kind of teach versatile
scheme Canada spent about 420 million on
grants and bursaries for students that
are studying so think about how we can
incentivize graduates you might create a
specific pathway secondly centralizing
continuing professional development into
a single portal so not getting rid of
diversity of different types of training
or suppliers of training make it much
easier for an individual learner to
access and thirdly extending the early
career framework to early years I think
it's worked very well in teaching and
should be moved across for increasing
opportunities to retrain so when the
lifelong loan entitlement is created as
part of the lifetime skills guarantee
you should be really pushing people to
study towards that level three diploma
for the early years Workforce where by a
public information campaign or using
intermediaries like trade bodies and
fifth apprenticeships so smes really
struggle to access the apprenticeship
system part of that is making the system
easier but it's also sort of the London
progression collaboration are a really
good example in London who have sought
to overcome some of those frictions in
nurseries or daycare centers taking on
apprentices so using I think all five of
those tools could help improve the flow
of skilled stuff and while that sounds
great while we've had evidence from
Child Care Providers freeing up staff to
be able to access training is a major
um challenge but I just want to ask one
final question whether you believe that
the
um Child Care announcements in the
spring budget actually do what it's
supposed to do or simply papering over
the cracks because there hasn't been
strategic enough to meet the changes
necessary to provide a high quality
early years
provision for all of those that need it
anyone it's a fantastic First Step there
is much more to do
um
I I was going to address the issue of
qualifications so I will let my
colleagues go first on that question
um yeah so I mean
I mean it's it's just kind of throwing
the other thing into the mix and
um we think there does need to be sort
of more focused strategy with clear
objectives so that we can actually make
policies that have a good chance of
meeting these objectives so our sort of
key recommendations really quickly are
that we need to weight funding much more
heavily towards children from low-income
families and children with disabilities
we need to ensure all the funded hours
are properly funded don't weaken ratios
fill the void in the early years
Workforce strategy and Encompass that
and also we haven't touched on this
session but the previous session did we
think that the re-expansion of the local
children's center model should continue
because that's a very important part of
things I mean I think to be to be fair
though the money which has been
announced in the budget wouldn't touch
the signs with that shot we list no I
mean and I I was I was happy to say we
need more money
yeah and I would just say on the
announcement it's um yeah it's the first
step it's weighted too much towards the
demand subsidy rather than supply side
but it will help some people
um but fundamentally we need to put
access affordability and availability at
the heart of this and that means um
supply side and just on qualifications
if I may
um I would draw a distinction between
having good development routes for staff
which they can use to progress and
improve their skills which I would very
much support and I think many of the
things which my colleague was saying are
very sensible there and having barriers
which prevent people with the skills
needed to working in there so I'm not a
fan of the GCSE maths requirement that
was alluded to in the previous session
um when I was in the department for
education I was very pleased that we
removed the GCSE maths and English
requirements for T levels I've also been
campaigning to have them removed from
apprenticeships I don't believe that
just because someone's not academic we
we should bar them perform using their
skills which may be very considerable in
other settings and many of the best
people who would be
brilliant at working with two three and
four-year-olds may not have the academic
skills to have passed GCSE maths or
English ditto with degrees fantastic to
have roots to encourage graduates in or
to encourage people who wished you to
work towards that but I wouldn't want it
to see it become a graduate only
profession
well I think that um
and two areas which could more be done
I'd Echo the call on apprenticeships
this is something where support for smes
support for even something supported at
the child care profession in particular
could be very very helpful we could also
look at T levels and T levels would be a
great route for taking 16 to 18 year
olds again you would probably need some
support for child care providers to
provide the placements the nine-week
placement is a big issue to take someone
on but actually it's a great way of
getting someone in who may then be able
to join the workforce immediately after
completion of that two level and it
would be a great way to get talented
people in that very point I was going to
bring in Andrew but Mayfield our
questions well I mean yes the the
disadvantage of being a late questioner
is that your sort of fabric of questions
has got lots of holes shot through it
already so I just wanted to see if
anyone has anything they'd like to add
about government action or government
getting out of the way but either way
what what what should governments Focus
be in terms of developing the child care
course in terms of what we've heard in
this session and the previous one about
the huge shortages and shortfalls that
we've got within it and I'll start with
you Adam and go along
um
in terms of things to add and I think
relates to the workforce issue I think
one of the challenges that has been
alluded to is the narrowness of some of
the subsidies that exist currently and
the complexity to parents although lots
of parents are aware of some of these
schemes particularly on tax-free child
care very few people uh take it up about
one and four that are eligible so that's
why I really do think that probably not
for now but certainly for the beginning
of a new Parliament
um any government should be looking at
moving towards a much more simplified
system so we've said a single Child Care
Credit that brought together at the
universal elements in one childcare
credit and then the means tested
elements into an advanced Joel okay
credit paid in advance in the form of a
voucher that can be used on both for
more provision but also things like
after school clubs with both and that
was paid directly to Providers as
opposed to going through local
authorities or any sort of government
system like the tax-free Child Care
would massively removed some of the
supply side barriers would increase
parental choice would decrease
administrative burdens on the payment
systems around some of those providers
too so that sort of ambitious system the
required apartments that I know don't
always like working together to work
together quite closely and I think that
is what the next priority needs to be
thank you I mean um nothing to add at
this particular point because I think
I've covered it all
yeah
um I don't think anything to add from me
either
right I I will just add that that we
have several times talked about what we
need as someone who's providing uh Child
Care early years education as if it's
one sort of specific set of
qualifications for everybody in a sector
that obviously needs a hugely diverse
range of skills and abilities within the
sector so I wonder we perhaps reflect
this in what we're going to say but this
you know you need to be a graduate you
need to have GCSE or you don't or you do
or child minders are different than than
more formal settings I just probably
need to explore at some point Thank You
chair thank you Ian yeah um I'm just
wanting to sort of look at I mean sort
of given given my accent you may guess I
come from one of the provinces of
England right so
um so um so what could the government do
to ensure that the new expansion the
child care subsidies also address
inequalities in access to Quality
education uh early years education
especially across different regions
friends
so one thing I would say is that I think
some of this some of this question
shouldn't be addressed through the free
child care offer I'd Echo what others
have said about the need to ensure that
we're working with young children
through other means through family hubs
do direct support for families I don't
think we should be assuming that all of
the sort of support is sort of you know
access to access to high quality
education should be run to through the
child care system
um
it it just will have a lot of people who
will fall do the cracks that way and
we've talked about how you know there's
a high dead weight costs in a lot of
those subsidies if you try and do it
that way end up accruing to well-off
families
what I do think is most important and
I'm going to come back to this
um availability as distinct from
affordability here and one of the things
which we've really seen has been a
problem with the fall off on child
minders in this as part of the system is
irregular
um irregular hours child care or
flexible child care so if you work
shifts for example then you know you
can't say well I want childcare every
Tuesday because you might not be working
every Tuesday and you can't say every
Thursday because you might not be
working every Thursday and actually you
will have child care settings who will
turn away people like that because they
say well because of my ratios I can't
have that I've got to have someone who's
every week because otherwise some weeks
I'm going to be only having three people
instead of four and I can't afford that
because I can't afford to make my staff
you also had child minders traditionally
would offer a lot more things you know
out of hours you want to just someone
who will look after two children going
on to 10 in the evening because their
mum's a nurse or their mum's working the
late shift at Tesco and they need that
setting
it seems to run counter to the overall
um labor market demand for much more
flexible employees in terms of when
they're available and you know having
people who can sort of you know drop do
everything in a drop of a hat and then
come in and do four hours and then go
home and then come back and do six hours
later you know yeah well traditionally
this was this was the role which was
filled by child minders who would take
smaller number of children than
nurseries and the fact that they have
gone out of the settings because we've
demanded the same from that sort of
casual provider of child care
um who was still you know doing a great
service to the parents he was looking
after the kids he was probably teaching
them staff providing them emotions
and unfortunately that's what many
employers are looking for you know
they're looking for no notice
flexibility from their staff and they're
not going to but they're not those sort
of providers aren't going to go in the
system where they've got to comply with
the same level of Regulation paperwork
that you know a busy being Nursery which
is a massive company with huge numbers
of people to take care of the paperwork
we've got to do if we want to get that
access to the disadvantaged people to
people working shifts we've got to
accept that you know there's great
flexibility in what I mean I'm much more
interested from the perspective of this
question is you know there are parts of
the country which are relatively
prosperous but with small islands of of
deprivation and there are other parts
that could be which are largely deprived
but with small pockets of prosperity so
how do you how do you compensate for
that around the country Tammy and then
I'll bring
um yeah so sort of going back to that
question actually I agree with the point
about children centers about investing
in that surestart model instead of
rejuvenating it because actually
um it's interesting because in research
and that I did at LSA with colleagues
there and we looked at sort of local
area variation in where people were able
to access preschool and what we found
was that that's in areas where there was
more sure start provision more children
went on to go to preschool and we think
this is because sort of in the detail in
terms of what's happening on the ground
because it's a kind of community Hub
orientated holistic service it kind of
built that trust it kind of joined up
with other things and then children then
accessed more sort of preschool more
child care so actually I agree with that
as one of the kind of solutions to the
local area disparities
I think this is one of the areas where
there's a real role for market
intermediaries so to say what I mean by
this there are going to be different
labor markets that require different
ship shift patterns and different types
of workers and often if you're a big
company whether you're in logistics
distribution whatever you need a lot of
people to do shift work you work through
an agency right you'll say and then
that's because they solve Collective
action problems you say I need a bunch
of workers for these times and they help
you do that now why don't we apply a
similar thing on child care so that's
where child minor agencies can play a
role they can get a difficult brief
about the type of workers that are
needed in an area what times they might
need to be available what premises they
might need what location they might need
to be in and they can help solve that
Collective action problem I get very
nervous about the state doing that or
even local government doing that because
they often can't be nimble or agile
enough so this is where I think there is
a role for CMAs in addressing some of
these gaps and helping parents get more
flexible care maybe you should look at
what's been happening with the supply
teacher Market recently but that's
another matter okay
okay um I think we've comprehensively
over our time thanks to the high quality
of the evidence we have from both panels
um so so thank you
um there's one last question I just
wanted to ask um which is I guess one of
for me missing elements in the budget
announcement um and perhaps a kind of
one word answer from the panel would be
would be great uh but we've heard in
this inquiry about many of the problems
with the tax-free Child Care offer and
and the fact that something which is
good on paper
um isn't really working for parents low
take up complexity of use Etc uh do you
believe that the tax-free Child Care
System needs to be rethought I think
Adam's already basically said yes yes I
mean yeah yes okay thank you